Chris starts off this hour in Tampa hi
Chris how are you good are you better
than I deserve what's up okay quick
background I'm 21 I started a lawn
service when I got out of high school
I'm 19
anyway I I make about forty five
thousand to fifty five thousand a year
and profit a live at home profit no
that's gross stop it I would say right
now it's about thirty five thousand
mm-hmm
and I still I still live at home I'm not
investing anything I just kind of want
to know what's the next step you know
and going forward here you have any
money
yeah I've got about five thousand okay
you got any debt no okay that's good
news all right what are you doing to
increase your income I work every day
well that's make any more income that's
making income I ask what you're doing to
increase your income
I'm just getting as many LAN accounts as
I can every day I've got a couple of
companies that I work for that have been
phenomenal and getting me more work so
and it's and not starting to grow too so
just act I mean just keep finding out
more companies and getting more work
good so you've got equipment to do all
this work with yes and where's the
equipment stored that story my parents
house okay where you live yes and all
right the the what do you want to be
doing when you're 31 or 41 well I would
like to keep doing what I'm doing just
do it on a bigger scale you know more
I'd like more long cruise and you know
doing more more different kind of things
like landscaping and irrigation and and
you know laying sod and even selling saw
you know things like that
I do a little bit now but you know I'm
still in the learning process with a lot
of things so I don't want to take on
something I don't know how to do yet I
wouldn't ask to ever send you
where you're going what do you do a
profit and loss statement on your
business yes every month yes okay and
you do a budget on your business I don't
do a budget on my business because I do
it because I project what I would do
that is a budget okay if you inject your
revenue and you project your expenses
next month and the next month and
through the end of the year or through
the next 12 months and you project your
revenue and you project your expenses
you have automatically projected your
profits you understand that right
revenue minus expenses equals profits if
you've got that projected out you have a
budget okay it doesn't have to be real
sophisticated but that's all budget is
is driving with the windshield not just
the rear view mirror the P&L is the
rearview mirror you follow me yeah okay
so you're man you're on top of it for 21
years old you're killing it I'm really
proud of ya you're doing really good so
if you if you know that you're gonna
make X number of dollars in a year then
the next thing is if you were to move
out what would be your household budget
and how do you afford rent and where
would you be renting and would you take
in a roommate or how would you do all of
that and then once you answer that
question if you can do it on what you
make now then it's time to move okay and
and as far as like in an investing in
retirement is that something to think
about now is that something to kind of
wait a little bit so I get settled in
and see how what what it does well I
want you to settle in and then I want
you to have an emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses before you
start investing because that's your
rainy day fund if something happens does
it for example if you got hurt you would
really have a problem with your income
right that would be an emergency and I
mean if you got hurt and it wasn't bad
but it just slowed you down right for a
little while you know for 90 days you
had trouble producing quite as much but
you could still you can still work but
quite like you could you know before
that that you need an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses once you
get that in place then I'm gonna be
there with you and but but you don't
have to have that to move out you've
just got to have the money to do the
deposits and be able to monthly doing
your budget afford to live and pay
groceries and lights and water and rent
and you need to late you know go shop
some places if I lived here here's what
it would cost if I lived there there's
what it would cost and in this situation
I'd have to have a roommate in this
situation I could park my equipment at
my house or I'm in an apartment and I
leave the equipment at mom and dad's
house I move out but I still use their
place to park my stuff and so on this is
the kind of thing you cuz you know some
apartment complexes aren't probably not
going to let you park for trailers of
equipment around there or whatever so
you just got to look at those kinds of
things and make that decision but yeah
you don't have to be financially whole
and investing before you move out you
just got to build pay your bills hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]